Question 1 - Samuel Asks, who do you think
is behind GUS, Missy seems too passive to
do something
like that?
Question 2 - Matt asks, when the Doctor was
talking to himself I thought it sounded a
bit like Tom Baker.
Was he
doing an homage?
Question 3 - Mahleks asks was there more to
the engineer character than we saw.
He seemed to have a suspicious amount
of knowledge, was he connected to GUS?
Question 4 - Glenn asks, I haven’t watched
any of the other doctor’s before.
Is Capaldi anything like the other doctors?
Question 5 - Gaming Funky asks, do you think
there’s any part of The Doctor that loves
Clara?
Question 6 - Hanah asks, when Clara said I
love you to Danny on the phone do you think
she was also talking about The Doctor?
Question 7 - Cyber asks, do you think the
mummy person is someone we know?
Question 8 - Dino asks, what was
the planet the Doctor
dropped
everyone
off at.
Question 9 - Suddenly Joy asks, when the Doctor
says things like “oh that was ages ago”,
is he going off and doing other things without
everyone.
Question 10 - DWFA asks, do you think Danny
will remember the Doctor from his childhood
and who do you think he killed during
the war
that he can’t talk about?